[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
Matt camp host audition extra take 22
and sure camellia Cabella at camellia
Cabela's at it and sure camellia Cabella
and Shawn Mendes with a hot couple right
now but I see her trading up for oh I
don't know a Lamar Jackson type hey it
worked for CR on Russell Wilson mat camp
will a fortune hosts audition take 15 oh
it looks like you've gone bankrupt just
like Jared Gauss fantasy career you got
nothing left
matt camp ellen guest house audition
take 27 alright I can't dance but you
know who can DeAndre Hopkins he's like
the Ellen of fantasy football matt camp
audition for oprah guest host because
she's coming back at some point right
you get it tight end and you get it
tight end and you get excited we all get
tight ends Matt Camp Saturday Night Live
audition take 59 all right now you got
it yeah I got it it's really simple all
you got to do is look in the camera and
say live from New York it's Saturday
night I got okay and action live from
Las Vegas it's your fantasy fire drill
why from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas is your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
your fantasy fire drill I am mad camp
and no I'm not hosting another show I'm
hosting this one right here and you
could join me every single Sunday
morning 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific on
all bleak to report platforms by the way
we'll see you later on in the week for a
special Thanksgiving episode we'll get
you ready for those three games but
right now it's week 12 that's week 13
what are we getting to hear injuries
inactives we have plenty of them coming
up we'll give you the sleepers for this
week and some a bonus ones there the
jump off very popular we'll give you
this week the quarterbacks you can get
ahead of on the waiver wire for weeks 14
15 and 16 we'll get to plenty of your
questions you tube I see all of it is
coming your way
this could be a make-or-break week for
you that's why I'm here to help you
let's do that right now we have the
inactives
and it's a big week for these once again
we get later on in the week you start to
think about players getting potentially
shut down in the coming weeks but let's
just talk about week 12 Matthew Stafford
is out now there's a report out there I
just saw it before I walked out that
they're thinking at least the
conversations about maybe shutting him
down he doesn't want that to happen
I do like Jeff Driskel as a potential
top 10 quarterback sleeper this week
consider it Adrian Peterson and then
Chris Thompson they are listed as
questionable we don't have an official
distinction for them yet I still like
Darius Geist the most out of the three
and why wouldn't the Redskins feature
their young running back with these
injuries while they're out of it I think
he's a flex with up side Evan Engram is
going to be out today for the Giants but
so is red Ellison so forget any of the
giant tight ends yeah you're playing
Golden Tate yeah you're playing Shepherd
wide receiver three with wide receiver
to upside for Shepherd I put tape more
in that two category and obviously we
hope sake one barkley not listed here
can get through the game without any
further injury Demaryius Thomas nothing
yet Warren just a thorn in the side if
you have Ryan Griffin who yes we gave
you as a sleeper last week tight end too
and then he got paid Congrats to him
we'll take a little credit for that
Crowder has been getting it done come on
Thomas is more annoying than anything
else
now James Conner juju Smith Schuster are
both out today you're still playing
Samuels a little bit more confidence
playing him in PPR is a really good RB
to juju out will give you a sleeper
coming up a little bit later on that
could benefit from Juju's absence AJ
is out again now look if you're looking
at the standings and saying you know in
three weeks I might not be playing
fantasy football cuz my season could be
over the trade deadline is coming up
talked to a team at the top of the
standings see if they'll give you
anything for AJ Green because he might
not come back at all so don't think too
far down the road and we'll get to more
of that later on Auden tape don't have
that update just yet I'm still really
only trusting Tyler Boyd and that's a
wide receiver three and then of course
Joe Mixon for the Bengals now this is
still the early game injuries that we
know of right now Alshon Jeffery is out
today look like he could play now Shawn
Jeffery is gonna be out today Jordan
Howard we don't have that update yet but
this came down from Adam Schefter
literally as are walking through Al
Shean Jeffries out today not to add a
lot of confidence Howard is not expected
to play Nelson Aguilar also not expected
to play look you're gonna play hurt czz
a top three tight end down Scott it's a
top tight top-10 tight end and then I
still think Myles Sanders is flexing
some upside but I don't care about the
backups here because the Eagles have the
worst receiving core in football Devante
Freeman's out Brian Hill said I don't
care about your fantasy team clearly not
because he sucked last week he's a flex
at best
Austin Hooper is outlook it's really in
Julio you know that you're playing Matt
Ryan now late game news and inactives
that we know at least injuries were
right now Tom Brady's elbow so it's fine
he's playing you know that
so is Julian Edelman I don't think
you're gonna see much in Justin knew if
he plays at all so skip them
same thing with Dorsett I think this is
a James White game taking on the Cowboys
I think the Cowboys are gonna win that
game now you're not gonna see a Marty
Cooper's name up here I'm still worried
about this injury like kind of think
they're lying a little bit to keep him
off the injury report because the guy
barely could play last week he's not on
it this week I think you're gonna see
the snap count coming to play but no he
is not listed on the injury so Amari
Cooper will be playing Matt Reed is out
though we know that now a little bit
more positive news coming on Kittel
Sanders and Samuel in the last 24 hours
they're all expected to play it came out
that George kid will play with a broken
bone in his ankle so if he plays that
was not that long ago look we're gonna
get to Ross to Ellie I'm telling you
right now he's on the sleepers if
Kittles out there do you have to play
him yes but I'm not ranking them inside
my top five so there's we're at right
now with what we know
with our injuries in an actives for
today's games but now let's get to your
first run what questions will get the
plenty of these on the show dick in week
12 maybe beyond if your trade deadline
is coming up we'll get there go get
those as well
Shepherd or gallop I'm gonna play gallop
he's been rolling right now I think
Michael gallop is gonna win people a
fantasy championship this year keeping
it up here tidal waves DK Metcalf for
Ronald Jones is my Flex I've man the
match up for Williams is pretty good I
might go in that direction Metcalf is
your high up side play against the
Eagles later on today
Brady Baker Darnell I'm gonna tell you
to play Baker Mayfield today yes indeed
I am I think this a potential top five
week for Baker against the dolphin so
yes I will tell you to do that a bo
Scarborough latavius Murray
I think the Lions will feed Scarborough
I featured him today as in my sleepers
article as well from Friday so I think
he'll be the guy don't like him as much
on Thursday more on that later on this
week Oh BJ cuff DJ more Devante Parker
my goodness what a group there I'm not
sitting Cup I know it's not been great
but I'm not sitting in and I'll play Oh
BJ tough spot there to sit two of those
guys yes Parker's been decent with
Kelsey on the by this league should I go
with hollister Griffin or Goddard look I
have Hollister ranked the highest in
this group
they've been featuring him he's been
getting a lot of targets I'll take the
targets it is certainly worth it they're
all three good names all guys that could
be started today people got up early
they came out to watch the show here in
Las Vegas you're watching more your
questions coming up but now we step into
the sports book we help out one of our
fans here hey what's your name Chris
Chris how can I help you so I've got a
non PPR flex decision needed I got
Darius guys Terrell Williams or Emmanuel
Sanders I need to win if I lose I'm done
so here's the problem we don't know if
Sanders is gonna play it's a late game I
think you play it safe with Tyrell
Williams he's got a good matchup today
cars been playing well I like cars a
quarterback you go Tyrolean perfect
thank you so much all right man good
luck to you win or go home maybe for the
same thing for you right now it's a
matte moment did Cooper cup have a bad
week last week
I don't know because I'm talking about
right here and right now some people say
Matt you can talk to your mother in 3
years and to that I say people will talk
this afternoon the bangles might be Oh
intended season but they haven't lost
yet today a buddy of mine said Matt am I
ever gonna get that $50 from you and I
said I don't know
William Patrick mahomes because Patrick
it's welcome in my home any day even
today
honest bye week you all are let's make
this fantasy our reality right here
right
[Music]
the harsh reality that your fantasy
season could be over by the end of
Monday Night Football it's a truth but
if you're playing in a do-or-die game
today if maybe this week week 13 coming
up could be the end of your season think
about that as you're putting together
your roster they're using David Johnson
there's talking to Kelly about this it's
like no it's like if your season's over
need to pick somebody up and fill in
that spot get rid of them
AJ Green may not be back next week or at
all the season he's no use to you if you
can't use them right now and your season
is on the line think about these things
think about who you can pick up if
you're not going to use Carson Wentz and
you don't feel confident about them drop
them go get somebody else your season is
on the line think about this week and
this week only we'll help out the people
at the top of the standings that's
coming up what we will do though right
now to help you out is get into those
sleepers how can we help you
we're gonna do it right now it's one
week we got your sleepers
[Music]
it's week 12 we have hit this we're
gonna take kitty to hit this waiver wire
has not been pretty you're playing the
one-week sleepers last week gave you a
Ryan Griffin tight end to vandal cop
Devo Samuel both top ten wide receivers
derrick karr QB 11 I'll take that and
we'll move along from them some of them
will come back into play believe me
we'll get into that but now we'll talk
about this quarterback right here you
drafted him high he stunk we're in post
type sleeper mode within the entire same
season with Baker Mayfield he's got the
Miami Dolphins today he's playing a
better football it's a good matchup for
him I'm gonna tell you that Baker may
feel it's got a top five Week in them I
do believe that he's at least a top 10
quarterback this week he's playing
better I think the hips doing better I
think there might have been a little
play calling change there in Cleveland
the bottom line is I like the matchup
for Baker and yes you can stream him
with confidence today so there's Baker
Mayfield for you move on to our next
sleeper and there's a caveat here I
think you know where we're going it's
Ross dwelle look if you don't want to
touch him because the Kidal hey take a
look at Dawson nob state I'll give you
that one for the Buffalo Bills but I'll
say this he scored two touchdowns he's
on a good team the report just came out
that George Kittel played with a broken
bone in his ankle less than a month ago
you don't recover from that completely
if he's out there today against the
Packers the matchup is good you're gonna
play Kidal but if you're really stuck
the matchup is good for Ross to le the
Niners are a good team maybe Kittles on
a snap count that's coming up later on
it's a very easy pivot to make but if
you don't want to touch that
you take a look at Dawson Knox now one
more here told you Juju's out today told
to James Connors out today another post
type sleeper all in one season you
drafted this guy to maybe be something
he hasn't been now the targets could be
there for James Washington
he's got the Bengals today that's an
excellent matchup we followed the
Bengals around all season long a winless
team Washington should get the targets
there especially with Connor and juju
out of the next couple more Jeff Driskel
I gave you both Scarborough I gave you
Dawson Knox I gave you all names to
consider even Rahim most hurt taking on
that banged up Packers and or be
debauched it's a Packers run defense
knowing that Matt Breda is out so all
supers consider there's some their
sleepers article comes out every single
Friday and our Thanksgiving show will
have specific Thanksgiving sleepers but
now we get to your questions here
once again all right what do we have
you're helping the people out for week
12 me on start Darius guys Brian Hill
Hollywood browner Deante Johnson I'll
say Hollywood's probably the safe play I
like the upside of guys because you can
hit the big play and I think it'll get
more opportunities with Peterson and
Thompson Bank double of those inactives
updates coming up a little bit i had new
england ''i but also zika tamari okay
two sides should I drop a bee Madison
for Cleveland defense versus Miami ahead
if you want to do that I don't think
need to keep Antonio Brown and roster as
simple as that so head yeah you can go
ahead and give that a shot go ahead Bell
or Sutton has my flex in a half point
I'm gonna go bail I trust them a little
bit more to get the touches so we'll go
with Lady on bail there next one is
Lindsey versus buffalo hunt versus
Lambie PPR I'm playing the upside I told
you Kareem hunt was gonna be a game
changer has been that way could win you
a championship and in PPR is gonna be
busy against the Dolphins today start
Terry Maclaurin or hunter Renzo Renzo
also on the sleeper list but I like
Terry Maclaurin a little bit more
inclusive guaranteed targets for the
Washington Redskins that or Winston look
if this is your season on the line I
know he's got the Patriots I'm playing
back Winston turned the ball over a way
too much to the wall we go for a fan
question hi guys it's Jill Kimmel I am
out here in beautiful Gilbert Arizona
enjoying this gorgeous 82 degree weather
at the park with my dog and I know some
of your gonna be jealous and really you
should be because it's very beautiful
but I do have a question about my
beloved Dallas Cowboys yes I know people
hate on them but I grew up in Las Vegas
and we didn't have a team so that's what
I picked and that's who I like so suck
it haters anyway I want to know if you
can help me with this I was wondering
why the Cowboys have such a hard time
scoring on the road against teams that
are not in their division can you guys
help me with that thanks Jill Kimmel
check her out her stand-ups tremendous
now she's a Cowboys fan she said why
does my team struggle on the road
against non divisional opponents well
the divisional opponents are the
Redskins stink Giants stink and the
Eagles average defense
so basically when they're playing better
teams on the road their struggles kind
of a normal thing in fantasy I mean they
do play in a controlled environment in
Dallas today against the paid
treats is not an easy matchup but I
think that's just kind of a normal thing
so also the coaching not so great in
Dallas but luckily dak is playing at the
highest level I still have Dax a top-ten
quarterback this week but he's certainly
not a top 5 option against the Patriots
Jill I think the Cowboys are gonna win
tonight believe it or not hopefully it
doesn't lead to an extension for Jason
there you go
I don't even know at this point laughing
here but you loved it so much and we
didn't get sued by MTV so it's time for
the quarterback jump off the jump ball
the jump-off still the jump off to jump
off now if you are top of your standings
we're not gonna live in the now but I'm
gonna tell you to get ahead on the
waiver wire you can streaming your
quarterbacks all season long and it's
been working don't stop doing it now
don't feel you have to go trade for a
big-time quarterback and hurt the rest
of your starting lineup get ahead on the
waiver wire looks to week 14 15 and 16
that's our fantasy playoff so who do I
like with good schedules in this time
about we start with this man right here
yes we like him today you might just
want to keep around Baker Mayfield look
I'm pulling the schedule back up here
because he's got well he's got the
Buccaneers he's got the Saints and he's
got the Panthers yeah you probably away
from that Saints game but two out of
those three weeks you got a good matchup
for Baker Mayfield
we're playing the matchups you might mix
and match you're streaming quarterbacks
which is why we'll move on to this
player by the way that's the cold
schedule Baker's got Cardinals in there
the Ravens in there in the band the
bengals this is reset so there's the
schedule I was talking about the
Buccaneers the Saints and the Panthers
for Jacoby Brissette in the playoff
weeks 14 15 16 also it helps that the
Colts will be in contention he has
something to play for we're gonna hope
that cy Hilton left the drops on
Thursday Night Football so one more this
goes against everything I stand for the
Ryan Fitzpatrick and the Dolphins have
the Bengals the Jets and the Giants in
weeks 14 15 and 16 we just pumped all
this up and go oh my god that's a
schedule I want that player well guess
what you're mixing and matching you're
in a deeper league he's got the matchup
javante Parker's been okay and he's
gonna throw it a bunch cuz no play from
behind or they'll have a game with open
over bunch so look I know it's not
pretty
but you can stream quarterback so win I
won with former Dolphins quarterback
Matt Moore before Derek Anderson wanted
me a fantasy championship you can do it
but now we get some more your question
let's do that right now
due to this is your time hello YouTube
what do you have for me here Nikhil
Harry over sterling in my Flex today no
we are not going that deep even with all
the injuries to the Patriots wide
receivers next one up here
Scarborough or Tate I'm still gonna go
tape there I think Scarborough will be
busy but I like Golden Tate more so
that's simple as that Courtland Sutton
or Tyrone Williams I'll play something
there I think we'll be quite busy in
that game so we'll go with Courtland
Sutton really they don't have a hell of
a lot going on with Denver Scarborough
Coker single - I knew - flexes well I'm
gonna roll with cook cuz he's been
getting it done and might be a top-five
tight end for the rest ease and I'll
play Singletary we'll play it safe there
instead of going Scarborough both
Scarborough America is running back this
week be the second wide receiver Boyd or
Beasley will go with Boyd don't really
like either guy too much that's a tough
spot to be in John Brown or David
Montgomery what do I always say play
John Brown does it always pay off for
the most part it does to the wall for a
celebrity question hey Matt it's Brett
Davern would you trade russell wilson
for lamar jackson check out that podcast
believe in the seahawks would I make
that trade I'd rather have Russell
Wilson and it's probably because his
receiving court is better Metcalf
Lockett Hollister throw with Josh Gordon
vs. what Mark Andrews Hollywood Brown
Willie Snead they're both playing in MVP
levels they'll probably want to and any
other season the other guy would win but
I would just stay with Russell Wilson
and be happy to have that but they're
probably one - right now in terms of
your quarterbacks thanks for that back
to enact as we go we have these updated
so we can tell you the updated
information for your early games Matthew
Stafford is out I do like Jeff Driskel
as a sleeper Adrian Peterson is going to
be active today for the Redskins Chris
Thompson is out today so same spot
you're in last week we saw guys later on
I would think they'd go to more guys -
Peterson's banged up but it's the
Redskins so let's call guys to flex with
RB - upside Evan Ingram's out so is
Rhett Ellison so forget about him
Demaryius Thomas is in more of a thorn
on the side if you're playing Crowder
we'll Ryan Griffin I'm not really
interested in playing Demaryius Thomas
now James Conner is out Juju's out we
like James Washington obviously as a
sleeper and you keep playing Jalen
Samuels there as well Deante Johnson
back from his concussion a deep sleeper
throw him in there AJ Green's out Auton
Auden
in I probably like to avoid them I
played Boyd over them and obviously Joe
makes me feel good about now other early
game inactives and this is a big one
here Philadelphia Eagles Jeffery is out
Jordan Howard is out and then Nelson
Aguilar is out so they're all out today
so you're feeling good about arts is
getting a bunch of targets Dallas got
it's a top ten running the tight end and
I think Sanders is going to get some
catches as well I don't care about any
of the other receivers here so Aguilar
out Howard out Jeffery out just forget
about the Eagles Freeman out Brian he'll
flex he doesn't care about your team
Austin Hooper's out that's we know about
for your early game inactives all
up-to-date now now late game and actives
and what we know has it stands Tom
Brady's gonna play we knew that Edelman
should play soon ooh not expecting even
if he does he's not worth it same thing
with Dorsett I expect a lot out of James
Wyatt catching passes out of the
backfield now also I should note you
don't see Amari Cooper on here they're
saying he's good to go I have my
reservations you're still going to play
them Matt Breda is out you're still
playing Tevin Coleman great matchup
against the Packers bad run defense if
you're struggling raheem most it is a
deep play George Kindle Sanders and debo
all seem like they're going to play
Kittel though is clearly not a hundred
percent if you're really stuck and
Kittles active you can play dwelle I
will say that I'm not as excited about
dwelle
if Kittel does play so if you have these
guys put them in your Flex so you can
make adjustments if needed but now it is
time to move even faster this is the
speed round
[Music]
this is week 12 this is moving fast this
coach my mental stability not so fast
your mental ability there's a lot of
questions there I got some news for you
right now though defense Seattle strong
this season to Damian clowny out today
that's gonna make it a bit deeper so
they lose a big piece there it's gonna
be tough but now we got a speed round I
got one more piece of news for you
friend of girl eggs little women in
theaters everywhere December 25th hit it
baby I have not seen that sponsorship
money but let's get to you guys right
now Cody would both Scarborough Brian
Hill and essenti we're gonna go both
Scarborough they're very simple let's
keep it moving here next up labia no
PJ's eggs in that I got a Zeke question
in week 12 are you really asking me
about starting to see Bill Elliott of
course is starting him won't throw BJ in
the other spot getting a bigger league
start Baker Jeff Driskel all two of my
sleeve for quarterbacks this week
let's get Baker in your lineup against
those Miami Dolphins next Metcalf
Sanders Crowder Sutton on Corey Sanders
plays later on but so does Metcalf or
Metcalf playing early I go Metcalf and
Sutton will play it safe we don't know
for sure that Sanders is gonna play you
can keep an eye on that yourself
Cara Rodgers always Aaron Rodgers tough
matchups go both ways yes who's got the
Niners but the Niners have to deal with
him as well so they playing pretty well
this season next well Hollywood Brown
ever be relevant again look we just call
the wide receiver three both for a big
play I think you could do so against the
Rams on Monday night next up here
Hollister versus Earths I'm not sitting
arts as much as I like Hollister Earths
could have like 20 targets today because
we saw the injuries of the Philadelphia
Eagle next up mark Anders our George
kiddo we know Kittles hurt Andrews is
about as reliable to get the tight end
don't mess around play Mark Andrews and
you'll be happy you did so life is just
the fantasy can you live this fantasy
life Aldo Nova said that what do you
think are we getting that existential at
week 12 did you say all don't know that
I did I saw him open for any money in 87
take me home tonight we release plugs
coming from next who's a good
replacement whirling Mack now that waves
out in most leagues I'm most certain
they he minds you missed out you
should've grabbed Jonathan Williams be
proactive on your waiver wire and you
won't miss out
Seahawks biggest
for the Bengals against Steelers I'll
play the Seahawks and I don't really
like either one of them hey that's it
I'm gonna jump in the app I got a car go
to the airport but I'll be on the app
for 30 minutes taking more of your
questions in the Bleacher Report app our
Thanksgiving show coming up this week
check that out and I'm back here next
Sunday and every Sunday 8:30 Pacific
11:30 Eastern on your fantasy fire drill
I'm at camp good luck to you in week 12
[Music]